bonsoir vous êtes historien militaire
professeur à Paris Sorbonne ancien
chercheur à l'OTAN on assiste en ce
moment dans l'est de l'Ukraine à une
guerre d'usure alors effectivement et ça
fait plusieurs mois que ça dure en fait
on est dans une guerre d'usure à
triple haut niveau d'abord parce que il
y a une véritable dimension symbolique
pour les deux camps soit à conquérir
soit à préserver barmut d'ailleurs il y
a une forme de symbolique qui sait
aujourd'hui cristallisé autour de de
cette ville une ville véritablement
martyre aujourd'hui que c'est le Verdun
ukrainien
la comparaison est loin d'être
finalement anodine Verdun c'était le
lieu où il y avait cette esprit de pas
de recul de la part des Français contre
une pression allemande extrêmement forte
là effectivement Mutatis mouton 10 on a
un petit peu
une un sacrifice véritablement dans des
deux camps mais pour des pour une
véritablement une interrogation sur
l'utilité stratégique de la ville même
si derrière il y a effectivement une
nécessité pour les uns et pour les
autres d'obtenir un effet pour les
Ukrainiens pour garantir le la
continuité du soutien de sa propre
opinion publique et puis des opinions
publiques occidentales en montrant que
ce sont les armes occidentales qui
aident à faire la différence mais que
cette différence elle ne tient que sur
le courage et la résistance des soldats
ukrainiens et c'est tout le message de
zenski et puis de l'autre les tensions
qui naissent aussi au sein des Russes
entre les l'armée russe je veux dire
régulière et puis les mercenaires de
Wagner avec des
tensions cette semaine et déclaration
contradictoires bien sûr et ce qui
montre bien d'ailleurs que au Kremlin
cette situation là c'est jouer les uns
contre les autres une forme de tension
permanente autour de
essayer de débloquer un peu cette
situation et ce sont énormément de
munitions qui sont utilisées aussi sur
le front en ce moment les munitions
c'est un peu le nerf de la guerre en ce
moment en Ukraine c'est le nerf de la
guerre parce qu'on a vu le retour de
l'artillerie on a vu quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas vu finalement depuis
presque la guerre de Corée véritablement
c'est-à-dire un usage extrêmement fort
de l'artillerie plus que des autres
types d'armes on estime que il y a
quelques mois encore les Russes
arrivaient à tirer à peu près 60 000
coups par jour
les Ukrainiens répondaient autour de
20000 aujourd'hui on est autour de
probablement quand les Ukrainiens en
tirent trois à quatre mille les Russes
répondent à 5 6000 c'est à dire que on
voit bien que dans les deux cas les
économies et les économies de guerre la
fabrication de munitions leur
acheminement jusqu'en première ligne
c'est quelque chose de compliqué et que
donc cette crise des obus là encore on
l'a vécu il y a quasiment 100 ans en
France pendant un un premier guerre
mondiale donc c'est là encore la
nécessité pour les économies de ce
merdent de bataille un an plus tard et
c'est quelque chose qui est mon avis
doit être observé voilà pour la
situation sur le terrain merci Guillaume
lascontari